bonjour
de politique samatan député du nord vice
président de l'assemblée nationale et
porte parole du rassemblement national
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale et on retrouve avec
plaisir christelle bertron aujourd'hui
espère un jour oriane bonjour sébastien
chez du coup free ciel du groupe la
dépêche bien évidemment on a beaucoup de
sujets abordés avoue sébastien chez nous
on va commencer par ce texte est
présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur qui prévoit une
augmentation des moyens pour les forces
de l'ordre pour la sécurité lierre les
abeilles board a dit augmentation de
8500 postes de policiers et gendarmes en
cinq ans dont 3000 en 2023 je
soutiendrai ce texte on ne s'opposera
jamais à l'augmentation des forces de
sécurité dans notre pays mais la réalité
c'est qu'il ya rien de nouveau sous le
soleil tout ça c'est la version ont
allégé d'un précédent projet doit tout
ça a déjà été annoncé tout ça est déjà
dans les cartons il n'ya pas d'effort
supplémentaire va falloir qu'elle gérald
darmanin elisabeth bornes arrête de
claironner des choses qui sont déjà acté
depuis fort longtemps mais de toute
façon nous nous souhaitons des moyens
supplémentaires dans le projet politique
de marine le pen pour la présidentielle
de mémoire c'était le recrutement de dix
mille effectifs supplémentaires il y
avait des policiers des gendarmes et
aussi les administratifs presque oui on
n'y est pas encore mais surtout derrière
la nécessité de trouver des vocations
face est le premier maillon qui ne
semble pas très anticipée par le
gouvernement je ne vois pas de campagne
de recrutement de sensibilisation et
quand on voit la façon dont sont traités
les policiers et les gendarmes en ce
pays trouver des vocations demain qu'est
ce que ce serait pas là c'est à dire il
ne sera pas atteint parce que plus on
dit pas qu'il ne sera pas atteint
j'espère qu'il sera atteint mais je dis
qu'effectivement on aura comme dans
toutes les professions d'autorité une
crise des vocations parce que ses
productions d'autorité ou de protection
des français c'est pareil chez les
pompiers qui ont de plus en plus de mal
à trouver des effectifs c'est pareil
pour les médecins qui se déplace dans
certains quartiers on a du mal
aujourd'hui à trouver des professionnels
pour protéger les français parce qu'ils
sont mal traités parce qu'ils ne sont
mis en danger et donc sur l'aspect des
effectifs il faut anticiper les choses
et puis la deuxième chose c'est à
anticiper les choses c'est à dire aussi
mieux considérer
financièrement ces forces de l'ordre
leur donner des moyens les moyens de
travailler les commissariats sont dans
le triste état bien souvent moi j'ai
invité le ministre de l'intérieur à
venir a donné un dans ma circonscription
j'espère qu'il fera cet effort pour voir
l'état dans lequel elle travaille et les
forces de l'ordre ça c'est la première
chose et puis évidemment le deuxième
maillon qui le plus difficile c'est la
justice parce que recruter des policiers
les mettre sur le terrain trois mille
l'année prochaine ça veut dire 500
effectivement physiquement présents sur
le terrain avec les rattrapages d'heures
supplémentaires les congés maladie etc
ça fait à peu près 500 personnes sur
terre bon bah derrière si le maillon de
la sécurité de la justice n'est pas
traitée justice particulièrement
déficient pour le voit encore avec le la
problématique du jeune
maxime roussel qui avait été un jeune
homme qui a été assassiné il ya dix ans
et dont on a vu que le meurtrier était
sortie et avait lui-même agressé un
chauffeur de taxi aujourd'hui bon bah si
cette problématique de la sécurité de la
récidive n'est pas traitée dans le pays
de la justice et de la récidive eh bien
ces effectifs ne servirons qu'on soit
clair vous êtes parti pour le voter ce
texte on pas voir ce qu'il ya dedans
c'est il est présenté ce matin moi je me
méfie toujours des effets d'annoncé
parce que y'a rien de nouveau et
derrière c'est souvent beaucoup de vent
brasse et on l'a vu avec l'affairé
q-cells sincèrement moi je me rappelle
de tout ce que nous ont raconté gérald
darmanin l'année dernière les
trafiquants de drogue ne dormirons plus
bon je pense que ça va il est huit
heures du matin je pense que tout le
monde dort bien tranquille les occulter
f seront toutes appliquées président
macron bon on veut qu'on lui rappelle
les chiffres je crois qu'il ya 10 % d
eau qu tf qui sont appliquées sur
territoire les féminicides étrangers
seront tous expulsés aussi je pense que
pas de problème tous les gens qui est
violente leurs conjointes et qui sont
étrangers sont toujours sur dix
récompenses le dialogue avec les pays
vers l'est
parce qu'on a vu dans la série
toulousaine que le problème du dialogue
avec les pays notamment le maroc pouvait
très bien se régler puisque le maroc
était partisan était d'accord pour un
grand vécu cette aventure scène ça fait
une semaine bientôt dix jours qu'ils
courent dans la nature là aussi on a un
sentiment d'humiliation permanente de
notre pays lorsqu'il s'agit d'ouvrir le
dossier de l'immigration donc je me
méfie des annonces de jardy en suisse un
mot là-dessus puisque vous avez dit que
vous souhaitez un changement de la loi
pour une facilité
une expo des expulsions est ce que vous
allez prendre une initiative à
l'assemblée nationale dès la rentrée
parlementaire oui mais de toute façon
vous savez nous les propositions qu'on a
fait on les refera je vous donne des
exemples simples on a vu proposer par
exemple des fiches et s soit connue des
maires des communes dans lesquelles ces
fiches s résident c'était un outil qui
coûtait pas un euro un outil
d'information je pense que dans
l'affairé q-cells a été bien utile que
le maire soit informée de la présence
d'un fichier savoir le codesa puisqu'il
était qu'il était imam et danse un
certain nombre de situations on se
serait bien intéressant que les maires
sache bon le gouvernement ne l'a pas
voulu mais la rente et du manque de la
part du gouvernement tunisien mise
l'intérieur il ya c'est plus qu'un trou
dans la raquette dans l'amphi riscle
scène je veux dire le type est en cavale
ça fait un mois qu'on parle de lui les
services de l'état n'ont pas été fichus
de surveiller pendant un mois
aujourd'hui il est dans la nature alors
qu'il devait être expulsé bon je vous
dit gérald amman sur celle ci on a connu
des ministres de l'intérieur qui après
une affaire comme le stade de france
plein deux affaires d'ailleurs comme au
stade de france et l'afrique you scène
on est rendu leur tablier avec un peu de
panache un peu d'élégance en disant je
n'ai pas été à la hauteur donc sous les
gendarmes au mirail brasil sous devant
mais à rien d'être ignoré une fois
positionnement pas puisque maintenant
vous avez un groupe la survie
le mans terre donc sa fiche
parlementaires du mois de janvier on va
voir ce qu'on met dedans on est en train
d'y réfléchir
ça peut être un sujet sécurité un sujet
l'immigration un sujet pouvoir d'achat
ça peut être plusieurs sujets on est en
train de regarder ça attentivement on en
parlait hier avec marine le pen mais il
y aura évidemment des propositions du
groupe rassemblement national en matière
de sécurité et d'immigration qui seront
excessivement
pertinente pointu chiffres et concrète
parce que ce qu'il faut c'est du
résultat mais je vous le dis sans avoir
rénové l'appareil judiciaire français
les moyens donnés à la police ne
suffiront pas
conseil des ministres ce matin celui sur
l'assurance-chômage quelques pistes
commencent à apparaître et notamment
l'idée de réduire la durée d'un 10 à
sion qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais
je crois que là encore le gouvernement
s'y prend du mauvais attrape le sujet
par le mauvais bout c'est à dire que moi
je veux leur bien je rencontre plein de
deux patrons de pme tpe qui ne trouvent
pas de gens pour travailler dans leur
entreprise ce n'est pas en tapant ceux
qui cherchent du boulot ce qui n'empêche
pas boucher d'accord pour qu'on
sanctionne des gens qui ne cherchent pas
effectivement de travail et qu'on
contrôle tout ça mais ce n'est pas en
faisant la chasse aux chômeurs qu'on va
résoudre le problème j'entendais ce
matin sur une chaîne concurrente un
patron de bar restaurant qui dit moi
j'ai besoin d'un cuisinier un cuisinier
ça se forme ce n'est pas parce qu'on va
réduire les allocations chômage de gens
qui ne trouvent pas d'emploi qu'on va
créer un cuisinier donc il faut faire un
effort sur la formation et
l'attractivité des métiers c'est la
raison pour laquelle nom propose aussi
une hausse de 10% des salaires de tous
les salaires négociés avec évidemment
les employeurs à travers une une
suspension
des charges patronales en échange de
cette suspension des charges patronales
une hausse des salaires si les salaires
ne sont pas meilleures si les gens ne
sont pas formés on pourra le
gouvernement pourra taper sur les
chômeurs temps qu'il faut c'est pas pour
ça qu'il trouvera des plus
entre les gens qui sont au chômage les
gens qui travaillent au niveau des
salaires ce que la rémunération ce qu'il
faut c'est que le travail soit
rémunérateur plus que le chômage ça
c'est une nécessité mais il n'empêche
que ce n'est pas en tapant sur les
chômeurs on créera des cuisiniers des
soudeurs des chaudronniers qui sont des
professions bien rémunérés d'ailleurs
mais qui manque sincèrement de
l'attractivité et pour d'autres
professions de positions qui sont mal
rémunérés les professions du soin
souvent sont très mal rémunérés donc
c'est un texte que vous ne raterez pas
sa texture est ce que cela nous ne le
voterons pas on va parler de la crise
énergétique un bon peut-être d'abord
avant de parler de ce qu'a dit emmanuel
macron sur la polémique ait lieu ces
derniers jours sur cette phrase de
christophe galtier l'entraîneur du psg
alors il a dit regretter sa blague sur
les chars à voile ça vous a choqué vous
bon menton pas sur nos grands shows
enfin moi je n'attends rien des
footballeurs je veux dire j'attends rien
les footballeurs qui ont des vies qui ne
ressemble pas aux nôtres les français de
faire les efforts et ça mérite bien sûr
je pense que ce qu'il sent bien c'est
que j'ai conscience que la vie ce n'est
pas leur vie la vie de la population ce
n'est pas leur vie
la deuxième chose je déteste les procès
en sorcellerie donc oui galtier est
mbappé ont fait une blague qui te
peut-être pas de très bon goût et enfin
ça suffit maintenant donc on peut plus
rien de rien on peut pas rire de du
dérèglement climatique c'est fini on
peut pas on peut plus rien de rien fait
c'est sandrine rousseau qui a gagné la
partie tant qu'on ne peut plus rire de
rien on va quand même pas les les
enfermer parce qu'ils ont fait une
blague et puis surtout c'est très
hypocrite quand il y avait deux bornes
les autres disent que c'est scandaleux
et c'est eux c'est pas terrible dans
cette blague moi je suis d'accord c'est
pas terrible mais enfin ça n'empêchera
pas tout cette équipe
politique d'aller au match au qatar dans
les mois qui viennent ça empêchera pas
avec hypocrisie d'aller soutenir nos
équipes au qatar dans un pays qui est
lexique or bien votre place il disait il
faut que l'équipe de france boycott
le partenariat que la france avec le
qatar concernant ces matches me sens
particulièrement indécent moi je pense
que d'ailleurs le ministre de
l'intérieur n'a pas répondu non plus à
ça parce qu'on envoie c'est qu'on en
voit des policiers au qatar on envoie
des forces de l'ordre pour les aider à
assurer la sécurité et l'accueil de
milliers centaines de milliers de
supporters on avait demandé combien de
femmes policiers étaient envoyés au
qatar on attend toujours la réponse je
pense que ça en dit long sur l'état
d'esprit ils viennent mcp il indiqué
j'appelle à sincèrement pour participer
à tout ça c'est moi je pense qu'on a
faim aujourd'hui les choses sont
avancées dans les choses sont avancées
donc ça va se faire donc c'est trop tard
va pas boycotter quelque chose qui est
en cours mais sincèrement il n'y avait
pas besoin d'aller au qatar pour le
faire il était plus intelligent de ne
pas le faire au qatar il appelle à la
sobriété qu'a lancé le président de la
république mi juillet puis à nouveau à
la rentrée est ce que vous le partagez
ce qu'il était nécessaire
de l'exprimer aussi fortement le
problème avec les modèles macron c'est
qu'en fait c'est d'abord un s'est jamais
de leur faute c'est jamais de sa faute
et medel macron c'est à dire que la
responsabilité c'est galtier la
responsabilité c'est les français qui
ont la clim faudra aussi qu'ils nous
racontent qui avec nîmes chez lui quand
il dit il faut arrêter la clim jeu
précis vous avez l'aqtim chez vous mais
enfin moi je connais peu de gens dans ma
circonscription et moi même j'ai pas la
clim donc totalement hors sol c'est les
français qui doivent - se chauffer et de
remettre des pulls et baisser le
chauffage et puis surtout on a le
sentiment que on passe notre temps à
payer les erreurs de ce gouvernement
c'est à dire que le gouvernement n'avait
pas anticipé les masques et les vaccins
confinement le gouvernement a une
politique du zigzag concernant le
nucléaire eh bien on en vient dire aux
français vous allez payer les erreurs
politiques de ce gouvernement vous ne
partagez pas l'analyse qui serait dire
offrant que les français doivent faire
des économies d'énergie actuellement
madame petit geste égale petites
économies donc les français qui sont
pleins de bonne volonté et veulent bien
faire des petits gestes dans le
quotidien mais ce n'est pas ça la
réalité nous oblige dire que ce n'est
pas ça qui va changer le cours des
choses ce qui changera le cours des
choses c'est une politique totalement
différente ses organes et le bas c'est
la politique us des contrats de libre
échange c'est la politique nucléaire
qu'il faut assumer dans ce pays et qu
emmanuel macron a refusé d'assumer en
fermant fessenheim ça ce sont des grands
gestes structurants pour l'économie du
pays pour le dérèglement climatique pour
la protection de notre planète ça ce
sont de grands gestes dire aux français
qu'on va cumuler les sanctions contre
qu'il faut se serrer la ceinture du
matin au soir c'est non seulement
irresponsables mais peu courageux parce
que monet de macron fait porter la
responsabilité sur le dos des français
alors que la responsabilité c'est la
sienne sur cette question juste cette
question du nucléaire puisque vous en
parlez olivier marleix qui elle présente
vous plaire publique à l'assemblée lui
vaut une commission d' enquête sur le
nucléaire pour pointer les
responsabilités du pouvoir dans la perte
d'indépendance énergétique singh bonne
initiative très bonne idée nous on est
d'accord on souhaitait une commission d'
enquête sur la gestion d'edf moi je
pense que il faut regarder un petit peu
qu'ils responsable de quoi je pense que
l macro et une immense responsabilité
dans le fait qu'aujourd'hui la france
soient obligés d'aller chercher de
l'électricité en allemagne puisque c'est
ce qu'il est un autre il veut aussi
réaliser la programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie qui prévoit la fermeture de
deux réacteurs nucléaires là aussi vous
soutenez ça moi je pense qu'il faut
sortir du marché européen d'électricité
je pense que la nécessité aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs le gouvernement n'est pas
clair non plus là dessus c'est sortir du
marché européen d'électricité pourquoi
parce qu'en fait l'électricité son prix
est indexé sur celui du gaz ne manque
pas de gaz en réalité en france
d'ailleurs les réserves en gaz sont
quasiment à 100% on demande pacbase on
ne manque pas de gaz mais notre
électricité est indexé sur le prix du
gaz par un système européen bruno le
maire avait dit à quelques temps oui
pour en sortir puis maintenant ils
disent on va changer ce mécanisme
européen d'électricité et puis à la fin
a rien n'aurait été fait
les formations non mais il faut aller
vers non seulement la réouverture d'un
maximum de réacteur nucléaire dans notre
pays la rénovation c'était aussi le plan
de grand carénage que proposait marine
le pen à la présidentielle un autre
débat animé cette rentrée politique
celui sur les la taxe sur les
super-profits vous aviez déposé en taxes
et sur ce sujet oui nous avons déposé un
texte sur ce sujet que ni les insoumis
ni les républicains n'ont voté vous
savez que cette taxe sur les
super-profits elle se fait dans d'autres
pays elle se fait en grande bretagne
elle se fait je crois en espagne
également en italie en tout cas d'autres
pays européens ont choisi de taxer les
super profits je pense que c'est une
nécessité et que c'est une nécessité pas
seulement symbolique d'une nécessité
économique
il y a des grandes entreprises pas
uniquement les entreprises d'énergie je
pense aussi à cm1 cgm par exemple qui
ont augmenté leurs bénéfices grâce ou à
cause de cette guerre en ukraine ils
doivent contribuer davantage à l'effort
national plus que les français eux mêmes
d'ailleurs sur le budget et vous irez
dialoguer avec adriana talent pour
préparer le texte ou pas et gabriela
talent c'est ce qu'on veut nous on veut
ce qui se fait ailleurs en europe on
veut baisser le coût des énergies la tva
sur les énergies à 5% vous avez vu là
encore en allemagne on baisse la tva sur
les énergies sur le gazon tous les cas à
7% pedro sanchez est annoncée à 5 % en
espagne gabriella talent si nous
écoutent ce matin c'est très bien ce
qu'on veut pas besoin d'aller
dialogue je n'en vois pas l'utilité
aujourd'hui ils vous ferez le budget à
non non non on va pas voter un budget
qui va à l' inverse de ce que nous
souhaitons nous nous souhaitons une
augmentation de 10% des salaires rien du
tout là dedans nous souhaitons une taxe
sur les super profits je ne vois rien
arriver là aussi politique du zig zag
permanent comprend plus rien madame
bornes étaient d'accord puis maintenant
c'est européen bruegel arrêtez donc bon
nous c'est au moins c'est clair on
souhaite cette taxe sur les
super-profits augmentation des salaires
taxe sur les super-profits tva à 5% sur
les énergies ya rien dans le budget on
va voter un budget qui ne rend pas aux
français leur argent mais pourquoi ne
pas aller à bercy justement pour essayer
de faire en sorte que gabriella talent
est ouvert au dialogue mais parce que je
pense que c'est un exercice d'enfumage
parce qu'en fait ils ne bougeront pas
d'un centimètre sur plusieurs sujets on
vient d'évoquer l'allocation chômage la
taxe sur les super-profits le budget
vous avez des points d'accord avec la
nuque est ce qu'il ya des discussions
entre vous est-ce que vous voterez des
choses ensemble est-ce qu' il peut y
avoir des accords pour mettre en
minorité le gouvernement non mais je
crois que ça se passe pas comme ça
saoule et notre obsession c'est pas de
mettre en minorité le gouvernement
contrairement à devenir m'agace mais
c'est de faire en sorte qu'une autre
politique sont menées pour le pays si
d'autres groupes politiques sont
d'accord avec nous et qu'il vote nos
propositions nous en sont ravis en tous
les cas nous nous savons voter les
propositions d'autres groupes politiques
à partir du moment où ça va dans la
logique dans la philosophie que nous
défendons rendre français à leur pays
rendre aux français leur argent donc moi
ça ne me gêne pas
parce qu'ils n'ont pas voté notre taxe
sur les super profits parce qu'ils ne
sont pas favorables à la hausse de 10%
des salaires pour tous les français qui
travaillent en fait là nul s'ils sont
dans la déconstruction dans le conflit
permanent dans la bordée lisation de
l'assemblée nationale mais derrière n'y
a pas grand-chose à parler du conseil
national la fondation oui vous avez
refusé d'y participer
alors qu'on avait trouvé plutôt
constructif en en ce début de session
parlementaire pour quelles raisons est
ce que vous ne voulez pas non ces
discussions mais parce qu' il existe
déjà des instances qui font ce travail
quand j'entends olivier ferrand dispensé
de celle de la rénovation va servir à
faire le diagnostic partagé des
problèmes de société française enfin le
bourg ce verbiage complètement ridicule
vous savez ce que disait alfred sauvy un
la démocratie c'est l'art de se diviser
moi je pense que recherchait des espèces
de consensus permanent qui aseptise tous
les débats celle inverse de notre peuple
qui a besoin de débattre et il ya des
instances de débat qui existe dans notre
pays il ya le parlement on voit bien que
les maquereaux cherche à contourner un
parlement qu'il n'a pas à sa main c'est
ça la réalité quel conseil économique et
social qui existe légèreté instance qui
réunissent les partis politiques les
parlementaires les élus locaux les
associations les syndicats comme le
conseil nationale de refondation propose
de le faire oui mais enfin écoutez il ya
le conseil économique et social vous
avez des acteurs du monde associatif
économique et social qui est
environnemental qui existe et vous avez
des chambres élu par les français qui
ont cette légitimité les deux sont
capables de dialoguer sans aucun
problème elles le font depuis toujours
alors on voit même que dans les régions
d'ailleurs et conseils économiques et
sociaux participent à la vie des régions
ya aucun problème avec ça donc toutes
ses instances lc existe si c'est pour
réinventer la poudre h et bien qu'il
faut toujours confié un peu de
responsabilité à françois bayrou qu'il
faut occuper les copains qu'il faut que
c'est très gênant
mais c'est surtout aussi parce qu'il n'a
pas le parlement à sa main il a fallu
assembler à sa main et il sait n'a
d'ailleurs et ça lui pose des
difficultés alors ils essayent de
contourner c'est pas responsables et
c'est pas courageux en termine en
parlant de votre parti puisque la course
à la présidence et lancez vous avez fait
votre choix vous en train de manger lège
non je n'ai pas encore fait mon choix
j'ai pas parrainer deux candidats je
voterai je dirais pour qui je vote mais
j'ai envie d'aborder la république oui
oui j'ai pas de problème avec ça mais je
renvoie ya plusieurs critères il se
trouve que j'en trouve pour l'instant
chez les deux il ya la fois de
l'expérience et de la capacité à
préparer l'avenir mais le vrai critère
pour moi c'est et c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont tous les deux à intéressant aliot
et bardella puis bon c'est bien qu'ils
aient le choix
c'est la préparation de 2027 la capacité
à organiser notre mouvement pour 2027 à
le mettre en état de marche pour
accompagner la candidature qui je
l'espère sera celle de marine le pen
je pense que c'est la meilleure donc ya
pas de raison qu'il ne le serait pas
elle est finalement run je sens qu'il ya
six mois je crois qu'elle n'a pas
terminé sa réflexion mais je veux être
un de ceux qui contribuent à
ce que cette réflexion aboutissent à une
candidature voilà moi en tous les cas
j'encourage marine le pen à continuer ce
dialogue très directs auxquels avec les
français pour aller ensuite redresser le
pays est ce que vous regardez d'un
regard attentif ce qui se passe chez les
républicains toujours je suis toujours
attentif à ce qui se passe dans une
famille politique que j'ai bien connu
puisque j'en étais avoir un impact sur
la vie du rassemblement national selon
mais en revanche je suis attentif mais
je pense que les républicains tout comme
leur miroir le parti socialiste ou ne
représentent non seulement pas l'avenir
que s'ils pensent plus rien chacun de
vous dire ce que pensent les
républicains sur le travail l'europe
l'immigration vous avez une quantité de
de sensibilité tellement différente qui
a plus de cohésion qui a pas de
l'incarnation donc moi je pense lui
aussi le conseil la présidence est
lancée ils ont un nouveau chef c'est
très bien sauf qu'il pense rien je veux
dire à part dire nous sommes la droite
c'est un peu comme vous êtes la droite
mais vous êtes mort c'est ça la réalité
on voit la droite est morte aujourd'hui
les républicains les valeurs portées par
la droite où les valeurs portées par la
gauche aujourd'hui elles sont réparties
équitablement sur l'échiquier politique
les valeurs les histoires des partis
politiques et ce qu'il représente sont
répartis sur l'échiquier digues mais les
républiques en tant que tel louis sont
morts oui est ce que le rassemblement
national aussi doit évoluer on voulait
bien sûr vous avez les outils politiques
sont faites pour évoluer pour
s'améliorer on parle pas des mêmes
partis aujourd'hui on parle pas de la et
sefyu on parle pas
du parti républicain etc je veux dire oh
bien sûr qu'il faut changer de nom
encore une fois
je suis je pas le sentiment que notre
nom pose problème je crois même qu'il
est assez fédérateur en revanche est ce
que vous avez vu on a évolué et déjà on
va vers plus de démocratie interne on a
deux candidats c'est pas le cas la
france insoumise même clémentine autain
déplorait que ce soit complètement
verrouillé par un petit club l'ami de
jean luc mélenchon donc nous on est un
parti politique mature on a une des
élections internes mais on doit encore
aller plus au fond du seau marine le pen
doit être candidate en 2100 blement
nationale il ne peut pas dépasser le nom
le pen pour vous je pense que c'est la
meilleure sincèrement si je trouvais qu
un autre candidat avait le niveau et la
capacité avec un marine le pen pour
incarner cette fonction présidentielle
et où ils n'ont pas de seine marine le
pen qui est la plus solide la plus
expérimentée la plus capée et je crois
que ça resterait que les français elle
est unique est-ce que l'évocation du
rassemblement national aujourd'hui c'est
d'occuper tout l'espace à droite et de
supplanter la place des républicains ben
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire occuper
l'espace à droite parce que je pense que
tous les bruits mais je pense que la
droite et la gauche je vous le disais
sont des notions qui pour moi sont
dépassés donc c'est d'occuper en tous
les cas tout l'espace populaire
patriotes souverainiste oui parce que
nous l'incarnons le mieux face à
macro qui occupent l'espace néo libérale
et européiste
merci sébastien choisi procure merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin
[Musique]